welcoming to the program today James
Howard Kunstler who's author of the
geography of nowhere the long emergency
too much magic and the for book world
made by hand novel series he also has a
twice weekly blog and podcasts can be
found at Kunstler dot-com so let's talk
I want to talk about New Urbanism with
you but I think maybe just to get our
audience sort of into this and your work
what are some of the main concerns you
have sort of about how at least the
United States is organized
geographically in terms of cities
suburbs rural areas etc what are some of
the top-level things that we should be
thinking about well you know I have my
new theory of history which is that
things happen because they seem like a
good idea at the time and suburban izing
America in the mid 20th century seemed
like a good idea at the time and it's
become extremely problematical you know
the way that we are inhabiting the
terrain of North America especially
considering the resource problem as we
face and the problems with capital or
let's say wealth or you know our
accumulated savings and we're facing a
situation that is you know we're gonna
we're gonna be short of resources
especially energy resources and the
interventions of our central banks have
really impaired capital formation so
there's going to be a lot less money to
deal with the problems we're facing well
some of those so some of the sort of
factors you talk about impact much more
than just sort of the urban rural
suburban landscape I'd be interested to
hear a little more as we can start
digging in now you know we saw this move
from the city into the creation of
suburbs some decades ago we're now
starting to see and have been seeing for
10 or 15 years the resurgence of cities
and that has led to gentrification it's
led to some cities including where we
are Boston Massachusetts New York and
other examples San Francisco becoming
incredibly expensive and we're now
learning all of the problems that that
brings as it connects to wealth
inequality so
specifically can you talk about what you
see today as the sort of on the ground
issues with the way in which populations
are organized between cities suburbs and
rural areas I think the main problem is
that the suburbs are a living
arrangement with no future
we're simply you know not going to have
the resources to live that way but a lot
of people don't realize that the way our
cities are organized too will prove to
be problematic that in fact they have
they've grown far too big they're
they're outs they are out scaling what
will be the resource realities of the
future and they're gonna have to
contract and the contraction is going to
be pretty disorderly and you know I
think we're going to see a whole new
disposition of how people live in
America and a lot of it will include the
resurgence of small towns small cities
places that have a meaningful
relationship with agriculture because
that's going to become a much more
important issue as you know oil and gas
based industrial agriculture gets into
trouble well some of the advocates of
this new urbanization would say it's not
so much that the cities will have to
scale down but the cities will have to
build a direct relationship to
agriculture whether its rooftop farms or
vertical farming within cities etc what
about that possibility that it's not
that's a misunderstanding of how reality
works explain well you know there is
such a thing as gardening that can take
place in the urban setting but you know
one of the unfortunate consequences of
the suburban fiasco is that an erased
our cultural memory of the distinction
between what's the town and what's the
country and there are certain there are
certain activities that are specific to
both and you know we're gonna have to do
the farming and the food production in
the place that is not the city and the
cities are gonna have to get smaller so
I I just disagree with that all idea
what about the future of the suburb
that's something I'm interested in as
well I mean we've talked with other
experts about how
suburbs are sort of fundamentally
designed to depend on vehicles to depend
on driving to sort of stymie community
creation except sort of in the most
forced and concocted ways just by their
very layout what about the possibility
or is there a possibility of turning
suburbs into small towns as independent
from the cities that they surround well
I think that there is a wish that we
could somehow retrofit them I don't
think the money is going to be there to
do that you know I think that the
suburbs really have three destinies
ruins
Salvage and slums and you know not much
beyond that and it's you know it's
unfortunate life is tragic and sometimes
we have to pay the consequences of
making bad choices and we've made some
very bad choices in this country you
know it's funny because there's a
program at MIT now which is kind of a an
offshoot of the Harvard landscape
urbanism program and the MIT program is
putting out a lot of propaganda about
the future of the suburb as a nirvana of
self-driving cars and and
computerization and this is the kind of
techno narcissism that I think is is
really going to get us into trouble
because you know the societies are
really emergent and self-organizing and
they have to comply with the mandates of
reality and I think we're gonna find
ourselves in a pretty bad collision with
reality in the years ahead talk a little
bit about your work new urbanism and
what you might see as sort of the
proscription going forward to better
organize the ways in which humans are
organizing around cities and suburbs and
small towns
well the newer urbanism arose in the
early 1990s as a reform movement among a
group of Architects urban designers
municipal officials developers it was a
pretty broad group of professionals who
recognized I think rightful
that the American suburb was a real
fiasco and that if we didn't figure out
another way to live on this on this
continent that we were gonna you know
our civilization was really going to get
into trouble and they dove into the
dumpster of history and they retrieved a
lot of information and methodology and
principle for traditional urban design
you know most of this stuff is uh
methods of designing and assembling
places for people to live that is a
human habitats that have been successful
for you know centuries if not thousands
of years and many of the basic
principles haven't changed you know that
the design and detailing of the street
the understanding that the buildings
have to have to form outdoor public
rooms that are comprehensible that make
people feel comfortable the idea that
the places we live have to be have to
work with our human neurology and you
know they set about to to you know prove
their point they built a lot of new town
developments around the United States
and also in Europe and Asia but I think
their main contribution was the
recoating of municipal laws all over
America to avert mandating the suburban
sprawl out outcome which had been
embedded in in law and custom and
building practice and really all of the
relationships that exist in the property
development industry
well that really gets not a question I
have about this which is is the solution
you're talking about zoning essentially
do you see the solution as coming from
the top down in that way I mean is there
something the individual can do well no
the solution is probably not going to
come from the top down I'm because that
it is the nation it's in the nature of
emergence that you know that just
doesn't happen what has happened is that
as many younger people have moved into
the planning profession you know they
they've realized that the suburban
mandates are insane and and you know
they they have joined the new urbanist
movement and in fact a lot of new
urbanist practice has now become you
know normal across the country but you
know the old habits die hard and there
are a lot of places especially in the
Midwest and the West where you know we
were still entertaining techno
narcissistic fantasies about the eternal
endless suburb so where do you live I
mean generally speaking not like your
address but but sort of where have you
chosen to live and how does that fit
into your views well I grew up in
Manhattan by the way you know and in the
center of the New York City so I've
experienced that but I'm living in a an
old factory Village in upstate New York
200 miles from New York City and you
know it's a it's a small town that has
the bones of the old economy but a lot
of the old economy is gone but you know
I think that these are that are the
kinds of places that will have a much
bigger role in America's future because
these are the place that I live in is a
place that still does have a
relationship with with agriculture a
meaningful one and it also has you know
the the bones of a small urban place
that is scaled to the realities of the
future so so I'm very optimistic about
what will happen with small-town America
and small city America I think we ought
to be very concerned about what our
gonna you know what will happen with the
great Metroplex cities because they are
they're really going to hit the wall
hard and you know when that happens it's
gonna be a very disorderly process we've
been speaking with James Howard Kunstler
you can check out his twice weekly blog
and podcasts at consular comm and of
course all issues that no matter where
you live there's there's really no way
to say I'm not going to participate in
this problem but by definition you are
part of this because you live somewhere
very important and super interesting
thanks for talking to me about it you're
quite welcome thank you